I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your questions are you prepared
to call h a terror group is it possible
of a rational can I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight appears moring uncensored
Professor Neil Ferguson is one of the
world's most eminent historians an
authority on civilization Empire and War
as we all try to make sense of a world
apparently on fire he joins me live to
try and explain it for us
live from London this is Pi's Morgan
uncensored well good evening from my
home in London and I'll explain why in a
moment but welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored grief doesn't work
differently in a war zone every number
means a ripple of misery a grieving
mother or a devastated brother or son
best friends whose laughter will never
be heard together again
the scale of the grief in Israel and
Gaza right now is incalculable and among
the dead are a simply staggering number
of people who gave their lives for their
duties and their jobs more than 100 Aid
workers more than 220 doctors nurses and
paramedics and so far 61 journalists
have been killed too four Israelis three
Lebanese and 54 Palestinians these were
all people who put their safety on the
line to keep other people alive and to
show the world what's really happening
now they've paid the ultimate price well
this anchoring correspondent broke down
in tears as they learned of the death of
a
[Music]
colleague well as I say grief doesn't
work any differently in a war zone in
fact it's more accentuated the committee
to protect journalist said 68 media
workers were killed worldwide last year
that makes the last month the deadliest
in recorded history for journalists Al
jazer journalist whale Dau was
broadcasting live when he heard the
Israeli air strike that hit the house
his family was Sheltering in he was
still on air when he took the call to
say that his wife his son his daughter
and his grandson had all been killed
I can't even begin to imagine how
somebody like him had the strength to
wake up in the morning after that and go
back to work but he did
his situation is a small window into the
hellish world of Journalism in the
world's deadliest war reporting in a
place like Gaza is extraordinarily
complicated and absolutely vital
International reporters just can't get
in Freely neither Israel nor Egypt will
allow them to enter unless they're
closely guarded and the local
journalists Gathering all of the footage
that we're seeing including those
working for big Western media Outlets
face the same life and death challenges
as everybody else they too will have
family members Under Fire all day every
day there is no safe place for any of
them to go the difference is that they
run towards danger with cameras and
microphones to help the rest of us
understand the reality of this war in a
world where many people think being a
war correspondent means sitting in their
parents' basements posting waspish takes
on Twitter now X they are maybe less
appreciated less noticed but they've
never been more important
well my first guest tonight uh I who
I'll introduce in a moment is the
perfect person to talk about all this
but before I get to him I going to
explain what I'm doing sitting here at
home uh in West London um I've never
done a show from my home before I've uh
got covid tested positive for covid this
afternoon and I be honest with you I
didn't know what the new rules were I
didn't know if you're supposed to just
crack on and go to work and merrily
infect all your co-worker workers or be
what I thought was probably the more
responsible thing to do which is to uh
try and do it from home so here we are
we've got a a great Twan crew with me
you both recently had covid um so that's
why they're with me and we're going to
try and get through it probably tonight
tomorrow and Thursday um and there's no
reason why we can't because let's face
it work from home is the new thing right
um anyway my my first guest like I said
is the perfect person I think to put
real perspective on the state of the
world right now there are so many things
I wanted to talk to him about in the
last few weeks of course the Israel
Hamas War Ukraine what is going to
happen there uh his great friend Henry
Kissinger who he's halfway through
writing a momentous volumes of biography
about um and what of course is happening
in London tomorrow with Boris Johnson
our former prime minister uh which
brings the link back to covid seems
quite ironic that IA go down with covid
just as Boris Johnson would be facing
the music at the public inquiry into
covid where many many including me
believe that he made a series of
shambolic errors and made some
successful moves like the vaccines but
made a lot of shambolic errors early on
which almost certainly cost many
thousands of lives so let me introduce
my guest he's one of the most eminent
historians and frankly uh knowledgeable
people uh that you'll ever see
interviewed on television is Professor
Neil Ferguson and he joins me now uh
Professor Neil Ferguson great to see you
um I can't think of a better time to
have you on the show so thank you for
joining me we got plenty of time to go
through all these things let me start
with CO as I'm sitting here uh with it
uh this virus which brought the whole
world to its knees um Boris Johnson up
tomorrow in London in front of an
inquiry what's the point of this inquiry
many saying it's got three or four years
to run by then as William hay former
leader of the conservative party here
wrote In The Times column yesterday
there might have been another pandemic
should we not be working as a planet on
how to prevent another pandemic rather
than worrying too much about what
happened last
time well appears it's good to be with
you uh I think it's good that there is
an attempt to work out what uh went
wrong what could have been done better
and let me just say that uh as I'm
speaking to you from the United States
the UK is doing more in this respect
than the US uh because although there
have been attempts to have an inquiry
into the Ling of Co in the United States
uh there really is no interest in
Washington in doing that and so the only
inquiries have been unofficial ones I
think there's a really important
question that needs to be asked by every
democracy uh particularly uh in the west
because many Eastern democracies handled
covid quite well why did the public
health systems do worse than was
expected prior to the pandemic peers the
US and the UK were rated respectively
number one and number two for
preparedness in the event of a pandemic
well they clearly did not come in first
and second in terms of their management
uh of the covid-19 pandemic and I think
there were two reasons for that uh one
was uh that the experts underestimated
initially the seriousness of the problem
even although it was clear that a
pandemic was brewing in January of 2020
I remember making the argument that it
was brewing in a column in in January uh
in the Sunday Times uh the experts
actually dithered in January and
February and into March uh and the
public health bureaucracies were
woefully unready when it became clear
belatedly how big the problem was the
second issue which I think is less
important has to do with leadership at
the time and still there's a great deal
of criticism of Boris Johnson and of
Donald Trump and I think it's fair to
say that they didn't do particularly
well but I don't think they were the
real reason why excess mortality was so
high uh in the UK and the us so I hope
that the conclusion of this inquiry is
not that it was all boris's fault
because I think that would be to miss
the much more important point that the
public health bureaucracies and not only
in the UK also in the US and in many
other countries really
underperformed are we prepared for
another pandemic to hit us do you think
I mean there's been a lot of Naval
gazing about individual countries
performance League table and so on but
if there if there was to be another one
next week next month next year and
apparently there's a 25% chance
according to the experts there might be
one in the next five years um do you
think we're ready for for that to happen
are we better prepared
now well I would hope so one reason that
uh countries such as Taiwan and South
Korea handled uh Co much better uh than
the UK and the US was that they had
learned the lessons from Stars which was
really the trailer uh for covid-19 and
the countries in uh the West really
hadn't because they thought uh not
having been much affected by SARS that
they should just worry about the next
influenza pandemic uh so I'm hoping that
there is a realization that you don't
get the the pandemic You're Expecting
necessarily uh but we can't really be
sure if for example we would react more
quickly to a new outbreak of of a new
disease
remember in some ways the virus that
caused covid-19 was not an especially
disastrous one by the standards of of
plagues in the past because it
disproportionately killed the elderly
imagine a virus that was as likely to
kill the very young as the very old or
or to kill people in the prime of life
that was a much more common feature of
pandemics in the past uh and really if
you look at the infection mortality rate
and then you adjust uh uh for age for
the for the number of days of Life lost
uh then covid-19 wasn't by any means one
of the world's worst pandemics are we
ready for something as bad as say the 19
1819 influenza I can't tell you that
peers the only consolation that I can
offer your viewers is that we did at
least learn uh in 2020 how to produce
efficacious vaccines very quickly and
although there continues to be
controversy about the vaccine
I'm one of those people who believes
they played a vital role uh in limiting
uh mortality and they were the great
success story on both sides of the
Atlantic uh and so if nothing else the
most important thing in a pandemic is to
get vaccines that work and get them
quickly so we at least proved that we
can do that and that was the one really
good uh piece of news that came out of
2020 yeah and I would give credit to
Boris Johnson uh for his work with that
unquestionably let me talk to before we
get to Israel Gaza which is obviously
the biggest news story in the world at
the moment let me just talk to you about
this issue of immigration in the UK
another big plan announced by the UK
government by another Home Secretary I
think it's the fifth we've had it was
the third Home Secretary to go to Rwanda
since they vowed to send Asylum Seekers
to Rwanda and so far no Asylum Seekers
have gone to Rwanda but there's also a
wider problem here not just of legal
migration uh but sorry legal migration
but also legal migration and it's it's
affecting the whole continent of Europe
and indeed uh wider parts of the world
what what's your assessment of how we
should deal with this new world of
millions of people wanting to move to in
their eyes a better
place well we do indeed peers live in an
age of mass migration uh though it's not
the first in history if you look at the
flows relative to population they were
comp huge in the late 19th century I I'm
myself an immigrant I I'm an immigrant
to the United States uh you might say I
also was an immigrant to England from
Scotland once upon a time and I'm
married to an asylum Seeker my my wife
aan hery Ali sought Asylum uh in the
Netherlands uh and so we as a a family
are hardly likely to be Hardline
opponents uh of immigration that would
be immense hypocrisy uh I think there
are a couple of really important points
that are worth making here uh the the
first is that if there's a sudden swing
in net migration if you suddenly go from
relatively little to a lot to hundreds
of thousands in the case of a country
like the UK uh you would expect there to
be some kind of public backlash and if
anything to me the surprising thing
about the UK today is that the Public's
been so tolerant of an extraordinary
surge uh in in net migration which is
certainly not I think what people
expected to be one of the consequences
of voting for brexit uh the interesting
thing is that if you look at opinion
polling uh there's no real evidence of
of racism of xenophobia when when
British people complain about
excessively large uh net migration
they're just complaining about the
impact on public services the kind of
services like the NHS that that come
under strain when there are suddenly
hundreds of of thousands more people uh
to serve uh so I think one lesson of
recent years is uh that one mustn't
allow there to be such big shifts
because while immigration is I think a
necessary part of the way the world
Works especially a world of aging
populations in many developed countries
it's important to recognize that that
people shouldn't expect it to come in
great in great surges the second point
is that I think you need to have a clear
and coherent policy that the public
understands uh and I think at the moment
in written there's the very opposite
there's really considerable confusion uh
and I must say the the swings in policy
as you mentioned the regular changes in
policy uh the somewhat outlandish notion
that people whose Asylum cases are
questioned will be sent to Rwanda none
of this has inspired public confidence
uh rather the opposite and one must
wonder why the Prime Minister would sack
a Home Secretary who'd called for more
restrictions and then just within a
matter of of days uh introduce uh new
restrictions of the sort that I think
soel braan had had called for so this is
calculated to confuse and disorient uh
the public as I said the impressive
thing to me is that the British Public's
remarkably tolerant I sometimes read in
the New York Times that brexit was
motivated by Imperial Nostalgia or
little
englandisntmycity Poland uh to being
people from outside the European Union
from as far a field as as Hong Kong uh
and other parts of Asia as well as North
Africa British people are remarkably
tolerant of this in fact uh in many ways
I think they even welcome it when it
helps keep the NHS working uh so the key
issue in Britain I think is that there
are public services under strain
especially in the Southeast housing of
course is a huge problem even without
immigration in the Southeast and to me
the only surprising thing is that people
aren't more indignant about this look at
the Netherlands to make one final point
in many European countries this issue is
causing earthquakes in the political
landscape new parties surging uh into
positions of power in Germany the
alternative for Germany and what happens
in Britain well nothing much really
happens because it's still a two-party
system and the arguments go on within
the conservative party and within the
labor party almost exactly as they did
when we were kids peers back in the
1960s and70s
and you know it's one of the reasons
I've been so incensed about this whole
Duke and Duchess of Sussex Oprah winfy
racism rout is that it painted this
country as a hot bed of of white
supremacists and racists right from the
very top with our royal family when in
fact all the evidence points to the
complete contrary that we are arguably
one of the most tolerant countries in
the
world I agree with that peers and in
fact if you look at uh the data uh
survey data and data on Behavior I think
you could make a very convincing case uh
that the United Kingdom is the most
tolerant country in the world um and I
always like to explain to Americans you
know the thing about the English is that
they really care a lot more about class
than they do about race I say this semi
jokingly actually if you look at the
data peers it's very striking how much
wider the disparities are in terms of
income and quality of life between white
and black Americans as compared with
their British counterparts uh and I I
would say one of the most striking
features of our lifetimes has been
Britain's transformation from an
overwhelmingly White Society into one
that particularly in the South but not
only in the South also in the Midlands
is really extraordinary ethnically and
religiously diverse and one might have
said as Enoch Powell of course did in
the late 1960s this will lead to
terrible trouble there'll be there'll be
uh there'll be blood in the streets or
in the in the river Tyber as he said in
his famous speech and that hasn't been
the case Enoch power was actually wrong
Britain's accepted this very enormous
change in its social in its social
aspects with remarkably little friction
in my
view yeah completely agree Professor
Ferguson I take a short break when I
come back and talk about two Wars Israel
Hamas which is now raging all through
Gaza and of course Ukraine Russia which
people are pretty much ignoring at the
moment but really shouldn't be we'll be
back after
[Music]
aak we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well Tred most dog owners will tell you
a can turn do you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seem have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
Phil sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come the
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved
this is really unfair what what what's
unfair if it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes course I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV it's the
only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncensored uh rather rare in fact unique
uh work from home
addition of P sensor because I am
currently suffering from covid but we'll
man up and crack on I'm with Professor
Neil Ferguson U NE I want to talk to you
about two Wars let's start with Israel
and Gaza and what is going on there I
I've spoken a lot in the last two months
about feeling a real moral quandry about
this in the sense I feel that Israel is
absolutely morally Justified to defend
itself from future attacks of the kind
we saw on October the 7th and if it has
a duty to defend its people uh given
that Hamas has said they want to keep
doing it again and again and again and
they're a terror group who will clearly
do that um but when you see the scale of
what is going on in Gaza the
displacement of well over a million
people now the the the leveling of most
of Northern Gaza and now they're heading
into the South to do the same and the
increasingly shocking death toll of
civilians and in particular children in
a place where half the population are
children you know I I'm beginning to
have like most people who who defend
Israel's right to defend itself a real
moral qual about the scale of of their
retribution which is how many people see
it what do you
think well I don't think it's just
retribution I think it's clear uh that
Israel can no longer coexist with Hamas
in control of Gaza uh if anybody doubted
that then those doubts were surely
dispelled on October the 7th with the
most hideous scenes of violence against
Jews since the Holocaust indeed it
seemed to me that what Hamas were really
trying to communicate was their
intention to reenact the Holocaust and I
think every one of us regardless of
whether we're Jewish or not has a moral
obligation to ensure that there never is
another Holocaust and those who threaten
to wipe Israel uh from the map uh are
intending nothing less than a second
Holocaust so the issue is can Hamas uh
be destroyed as it should be at at an an
acceptable cost uh it's the same
question that had to be asked uh when
British and American forces were uh
fighting an Insurgency uh in Iraqi
cities it's the same question that had
to be asked when uh it was Islamic State
uh that was being wiped out and since
these uh organizations specialize in
concealing themselves in densely
populated Urban centers uh it's
inconceivable that they can be defeated
at zero cost uh to civilians uh now the
problem for Israel is that it's damned
whatever it does if it uh If It Moves
civilians out of the way it's accused of
ethnic cleansing if it doesn't it's
hypocritically accused uh of genocide uh
so this is a a very very difficult
indeed well nigh impossible situation
and it's not made any easier when the
International Community and indeed the
US government leans on Israel uh to stop
or pause or cease fire because that only
allows Hamas to regroup and it almost
certainly prolongs the conflict I want
to add another Point Piers this is not
just about Gaza it's also about the
other areas where Israel is under attack
uh it's about the unstable situation in
the West Bank uh it's about the
possibility that at any moment Hezbollah
could launch a massive bombardment of
rockets and missiles uh from Lebanon in
into Israel and and there's more because
there are also all kinds of uh forces in
Syria that bear ill will uh towards
Israel the war has the potential to
escalate and grow in multiple ways we're
in a kind of lull at the moment
incredible though it may seem to say
that and my fear is that at some point
in the coming weeks we'll see the next
phase of the war a new front will be
opened up and Israel will be fighting
not only in Gaza but potentially
elsewhere uh for its very survival and I
want to underline to your viewers given
the very small size uh of Israel and its
vulnerability in the neighborhood where
it's almost entirely surrounded by
hostile forces its very survival is at
stake uh so I think it's very important
particularly for people in Britain and
the us not to be swayed by the very
clever propaganda that comes out uh of
Gaza often uh Hamas crafted often Hamas
authorized which is designed to make you
think there's some moral equivalence
here
uh because there really can't be moral
equivalence when Israel is retaliating
for the appalling attacks of October the
7th and that is a just war that is being
fought right now is war ever clean no
are there civilian casualties in War
nearly always particularly in modern
times that's the reality and I'm afraid
uh we have more to face of this harsh
reality because this war is only like
likely to escalate in the coming
weeks how does it end I mean you're a
historian you you have covered many
conflicts and Wars um I I just worry
about whether Israel has an end game
here that doesn't just involve in many
of their eyes in the leadership just
taking over Gaza for example occupying
it completely going forward do you see
anything other than that
happening well there's no great appetite
uh within the Israeli military for an
occupation of Gaza because they have
bitter memories of uh of what that was
like before and indeed what other
occupations that the Israeli Army the
Israeli Defense Forces have have carried
out in the past but who has a better
idea at this point it's a little
difficult to imagine uh the dust
settling and a new uh Force emerging to
take the place of Hamas that isn't just
as bad it's not like the Palestinian
Authority is about to be put back in
charge of Gaza everybody knows that
Palestinian Authority is an oxymoron
those two words no longer meaningfully
Belong Together there are some other
options which I think need to be
considered uh after all what's the
United Nations for if it's not to send
blue helmets into dangerous territories
where the alternative is ongoing
conflict and that seems to me to be the
kind of thing that should be under much
more serious discussion at the moment
internationalizing Gaza U that seems the
kind of uh end game that would make much
more sense to me than an Israeli
occupation that would almost certainly
just become a a succession of of
terrorist attacks and and counter
measures yeah I agree um just want to
turn briefly to Ukraine because
obviously Ukraine has almost been
forgotten at the moment at a very
worrying time if you're president
zalinski with American Financial support
for their military Endeavors looking
like it's pretty perilous in terms of
future uh Financial input where are we
with this Ukraine war is it as some
people fear now inevitable that there
will have to be some kind of deal that
involves Putin swallowing up some if not
all of the land that he has barbarically
stolen well Pierce 20 years ago I I
wrote a book called American Colossus
and I argued there that one of the
problems of American power is the
attention deficit disorder that kicks in
usually uh after after a couple of years
of any engagement and even when the
engagement isn't one that involves
American troops in the front line and
sure enough American interest has been
on the way uh in the course uh of the
last uh several months to the point that
there are real question marks over the
continuation of American Aid and
American Aid is pretty crucial uh both
militarily and financially in the U in
the European Union too uh as well as in
the UK one has the sense and a Ukrainian
friend said this to me yesterday that
people's interest has just wanded my
friend was saying that the CNN operation
in Kev has been relocated to the Middle
East as a kind of symbol that a new
story is in town and the old story is no
longer really getting the ratings this
is very concerning for any friend of
Ukraine and I consider myself a stonch
friend uh of Ukraine I've been to that
country almost every year for the past
decade because the scenario isn't
inconceivable that they could lose this
war Russians are a massing fire power
they have greater raw resources they
have the capacity to launch an air war
against Ukraine uh in the coming weeks
that could paralyze Ukraine's
electricity system if it's successful uh
and so it's not so much that there's
going to be some nasty compromise deal I
don't think President Putin's interested
in negotiation he's playing for higher
Stakes because he senses that the
politics in the west is going his way
and he has a shot at Victory if he's
patient and that's the thing that really
concerns me we sort of lost interest
we're focused on the next War the next
shiny bright object and while we're not
paying attention we could see Ukraine
defeated and Pi Piers mark my words if
Ukraine is defeated that will send a
signal not only to Putin it'll send a
signal to xianping and China it'll send
a signal to the Ayatollah in Iran it'll
send a signal to Pyongyang to North
Korea and the signal will be the West is
weak it cannot sustain its commitments
it can't even hold uh Ukraine up in the
face of a Russian attack and and that
will spell the beginning of a very dark
age in which the 2020s will start to
feel enough a lot like the 1930s so the
stakes are extremely high and I urge
people do not lose interest in Ukraine
it is vitally important that Russia not
win this
war absolutely it's about freedom and
democracy and we used to go to world
wars to preserve and defend that and
it's terrifying to me to see so many
people who are prepared to let Putin
take what he's what he's stolen uh we
come back after the break uh Professor
Fergus talk about two very divisive
polarizing figures arguably the two most
polarizing of the last 50 years Henry
Kissinger a giant of modern history um
who you've written a compelling
biography about in fact you're halfway
through I think a series of volumes and
also Donald Trump who is poised to make
potentially the most Sensational
comeback in American presidential
history could that happen I'll ask you
after the
[Music]
break
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about talk today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing Al in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy and need
to be one human per machine to come and
rectify beeps and the clanks and when it
goes wrong unexpected item in bagging
area I know are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
unit which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine is actually not
my job to answer your question are you
prepared to call a terror group is it
possible to have a rational you talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
[Music]
truth
this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back to Pi Morgan uncensored
live from my home because I'm currently
got covid um Professor Ferguson I talk
to you about two very polarizing figures
one who sadly uh died in the last few
days Henry Kissinger who you've been a
biographer of who I don't think I've
ever seen anyone who got such
extraordinarily different obituaries
depending on what media you were looking
at or reading at the time he was either
a despotic monster and warmonger or he
was one of the pivotal and great figures
of modern times uh I know that you sit
more in the in the latter but do you
understand why he even in death incited
such extraordinary range of
opinions yes so I think I I do
understand that appear I I've spent a
good chunk of the last 20 years working
on Henry Kissinger's life I'm in the
midst of a second volume of his uh life
as we speak and one of the Striking
features of that extraordinary 100-year
life uh was how polarizing Henry kisher
was uh from a very early stage he had
Critics on both the right and the left
over time the left became somehow more
and more vituperative especially after
the end of the Cold War uh and an old
friend of mine Christopher Hitchens did
a great deal of damage in this regard
with a rather hastily written book
called The Trial of Henry Kissinger in
which he made the claim on the basis of
almost no evidence that somehow Henry
Kissinger was a war criminal well that
really caught on and for a generation
who really didn't know a great deal
about the Cold War it became convenient
to say that about Henry Kissinger now in
in reality uh that really doesn't make
any sense at all because the kinds of
things of which Henry kusher is Accused
uh using bombing against civilians in
Cambodia for example or supporting
right-wing governments in Chile are the
things that secretaries of State have
done pretty much throughout the period
since 1945 so to put it really crudely
they're either all war criminals or uh
as seems more likely none of them is uh
this is a really important point to make
but the second point I'd make uh is that
if Henry Kissinger had not been Jewish I
do not think the vup paration would have
been anything like as serious the no
question in my mind that part of what
motivates people to hate Kissinger is
conscious or unconscious anti-Semitism
and it's been very obvious since his
death that people have been prepared to
say absolutely shameful things about him
uh literally within days of of his death
and I don't think that you you find that
kind of thing uh without there being
some elements of anti-Semitism and that
I think is the harsh
reality I mean of course the irony is
the second person I want to talk to you
about Donald Trump is somebody who
almost certainly when he dies and he's
not Jewish will get almost exactly the
same kind of polarized coverage of his
death um but let me ask you instead of
that about the prospect of him
potentially winning in 2024 you've got
to say looking at the Republican polls
for nominee and then looking at the
matchup polls between Trump and Biden if
indeed Biden is the Democrat nominee and
I know that you share my I think that he
he should stand aside but if it is Biden
Trump trump has a very good chance of
winning doesn't
he at this point if it goes all the way
uh to a rerun of 2020 and it's Donald
Trump and Joe Biden on the ballot then I
think Donald Trump has a better than 50%
chance of winning especially if it seems
clear the US economy is going to slow
down in the coming year if not go into
recession and Trump is polling strongly
uh in the swing states that are really
going to to be decisive as they always
are uh in the close elections that we
have these days but American politics is
an unpredictable game partly because the
stakes are so high and I don't rule out
an upset on on one or possibly both
sides don't rule out uh Nikki Haley as a
contender for the Republican nomination
there are plenty of Republicans in those
key early States Iowa and New Hampshire
who have some doubts about whether they
really want Donald Trump all over again
whether they're ready for another four
years of fire and fury and then on the
Democratic side there's really
widespread concern that Joe Biden is
over the hill and should not be the
candidate they just can't work out quite
how to get him to step aside the way say
Lyndon Johnson did in ' 68 when it was
clear that he was going to struggle to
win not because of age but because of of
Vietnam so I'm not I'm not ready to say
this is a two-horse race and and Trump
is going to get reelected I think it's
it's much too early to make that kind of
confident judgment there are Sur prises
ahead uh but at the moment the base case
is that it's Trump Biden and if it is
Trump Biden then I think Trump has to be
the
favorite yeah I completely agree uh
Professor I've got to leave it there but
thank you because when I discovered I
had Co today and felt to be honest
pretty rough and knew I couldn't do much
of my normal overan animated talking and
I realized you were my main guest I
breathed the sigh of relief knowing that
I could just basically tee you up and
let you talk and the viewers would be a
lot more what you had to say than
anything my croaky voice could come out
with so I appreciate it very much indeed
thank
you get well soon
Piers I'll try what un sensored next uh
Prince Harry back in court again two
biological men dominate a women's race
again lot to discuss with my pack
Constantine kissing and AA
[Music]
Santina
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we're
on your smart speaker as well criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
sport today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what do we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on T TV sitting on his fat ass talking
liit if you're walking towards me and
you're a she have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in 3 years hundreds and hundreds of mice
in a box which he walks into a branch of
McDonald MC mous man MC mous man MC he
should be easy enough to catch this guy
shouldn't he I mean he's got a house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
fil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party hi
off kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational you can't
can you I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
coming up on the independent republic of
mik Graham tonight and we'll be talking
to the mother of a young man a
26-year-old young man who was shot and
taken hostage by Hamas on October the
7th ever since then uh he has been
hidden from view he has been hiding with
the Hamas terrorist somewhere inside
Gaza nobody knows if he's still alive
nobody knows exactly what we're going to
be finding out tonight um but it's going
to be something that you will not want
to miss I'm Mike
[Music]
R well welcome back to uncensored uh
from my home in London where I have
covid but we're battling on here as I
would expect people to do even if
they're working from home joining me now
is my Pat legal journalist Ava Santina
and the author podcast host and comedian
Constantine kissim well welcome uh to
both of you so Constantine great to have
you finally on the program because I can
finally hold you to account for
something that you tweeted to me um I
was just curious really what what you
were thinking when you did this because
I tweeted this after a few days of the
of the war the appalling images and
accounts of what innocent Israeli
suffered on October the 7th are utterly
heartbreaking and so are the appalling
images in accountant of what innocent
Palestinians have suffered since then if
you disagree with any part of this you
have no Humanity or moral compass and
you replied the appalling images and
accounts of the polya to utterly
heartbreaking and so are the appalling
images and accounts of what innocent
Germans in Dresden suffered if you
disagree with any of this you've lost
your humanity and I've got to say in a
moment I was a bit annoyed by it and
then I thought longer about what you
were saying and I thought you made a
very good point and it's a point that
many people I have to say mainly on the
Israel Defense Force side have made
quite forcefully since which is that if
this War uh was being waged on social
media if the World War II was being
waged the same way with social media the
way it is then would the actions of the
Allies against German civilians be
judged differently and I think they
probably would I think you're right well
yes I think I am right Piers uh but also
the other thing I would say is I share
the moral quandry that you were talking
about with Neil Ferguson earlier nobody
can look at the pictures of what we're
seeing from Gaza and be in any way happy
about what is happening but I think if
we're being honest let's look at what
the Allies Britain and the Americans did
during the last year of World War II we
dropped more than a hirosima a a day on
Germany for a year nonstop in order to
win that war and I think if you look at
it from Israel's point of view uh
imagine what what the equivalent of that
would be here in the UK it would be
equivalent of say the IRA during the
troubles uh invading Northern England
killing over 8,000 people taking a
thousand people hostage and what do you
think Margaret Thatcher would have done
I think we have to be clear about about
the moral the inability to make a moral
comparison between these two while
having every bit of compassion for
innocent civilians who are caught up in
this AA my whole issue here is and
whenever I talk to anyone from Israeli
government and I asked them a
straightforward question how many Hamas
terrorists are you actually killing it's
pretty clear from their answers they
don't know uh I mean they kind of they
try and faint it a bit and try and make
out they know but they don't actually
know and what we do know from the
admittedly Hamas run health authority
but their numbers are not being
contradicted by independent bodies is
that the number of civilians dying is
massive and if you can't provide
evidence of how many Hamas terrorists
are getting killed then the the moral
position that Israel finds itself in in
terms of public opinion around the world
starts to erode quite fast I think well
the problem you have there is that
Israel and the IDF won't allow
journalists to go into the Gaza Strip
strip and that's also being you know
aided by Egypt who also won't allow
journalists to cross the raff of
Crossing so it's very difficult to
independently verify what is going on on
the Gaza Strip but you know also back to
what you were just talking about there
with Constantine you know I would say in
terms of the scale it's very similar to
what happened in Dresden but you would
never have that now because we've got
the Geneva Convention in place and
you've also got the European Court of
Human Rights and those two pieces of
legislation should tell us that the
killing that is going on in Gaza is
absolutely atrocious and is you know in
violation of international
law C talk to you about Prince Harry
it's not a subject I ever willingly
bring up uh from a sense of personal Joy
about wanting to discuss him uh however
he keeps putting himself back in the
news and he's in court again in London
today demanding to have Royal protection
whenever he and his family are in the UK
despite quitting the country quitting
Royal Duty and spending the last few
years trashing the family and the
monarchy should he be entitled to have
Royal protection well actually uh even
in the core case that is now happening
one of the things that is clear is that
he was being offered protection as any
high-profile public figure would be in
the UK it was simply not at the level of
that a working Royal would be offered
and appears you say you don't bring this
up willingly I don't really pay much
attention to these people but I do
remember distinctly some time ago them
quitting public life and moving on and
since then all we have seen is them
complaining about one thing after
another first there was the fake racism
about the baby now it's this and it just
never seems to stop and it seems to me
that they quite enjoy their attention I
know that's a cynical interpretation but
it just seems to me that they can't live
without the attention and they're
quoting it
deliberately yeah and AA you know I
talked with Neil Ferguson about this
secondary issue of the way that they
tainted with that Oprah interview the
entire country via the prism of our
figureheads the royal family and the
monarchy as a bunch of callous racists
when in fact you know this is from a
historian like Neil who knows better
than most uh what a racist intolerant
place looks like and he you know by any
normal metric Britain is one of the most
tolerant places in the world I think
that you I mean I think you know what
you're saying there you know you've made
a decision that the royal family haven't
done anything racist and there's not
going to be any further scrutiny of
whether you know anyone in the royal
family said something to upset Megan but
look you know we were all there for the
last couple of years and the couple of
years leading up to their well sorry not
a couple of years but the couple of
months leading up to their wedding we do
know how the Press treated Mega Markle
and we do know that there were a lot of
allegations made against her that I'm
sorry they could be called racist you
know she she had a very terrible time
look I'm not going to go over all the
accusations I mean there was well name
one okay so her skin color was you know
she was called exotic that was a pretty
racist thing to say and you know yeah
that was Rachel Rachel Johnson used
reize if anyone Rachel has yes has you
know corrected that in you know the
years followed that but you know there
were many there were accusations leveled
at her that were completely unfair I
mean there was a two-page spread given
to her consumption avoc to it was
totally
ridiculous but they weren't racist and
my point is if if you go back and look
at the Press coverage on the wedding day
for example I know I wrote The Man on
Sunday's big piece on it um everyone was
welcoming in this country the idea of a
biracial marriage into the royal family
not
a Ting racism actually pretty much
everybody that's fans of the Premier
League aren't racist and we do know that
people who comment on you know all the
footballers Instagrams after every
single match do put racist comments on
there but you can make an argument that
the Premier League itself is not racist
look I think there was a level of
introspection that was leveled at Megan
marle that was totally unfair totally
uncalled for and no wonder she basically
had a breakdown had to leave the
country yeah I don't think it was that
at all I think she was a very cynical
person who decided to hook her Clause
into Prince Harry as a meal ticket for
Life dragged him back to California for
the good life in the Mansion where they
trade off their Royal titles for
hundreds of millions of dollars and I
think it's despicable however we can
agree to disagree maybe on this one we
might find some agreement uh Constantine
this uh once again this issue of trans
athletes competing in women's sport has
reared a very ugly head in terms of what
happened in Illinois in a cycling
competition a women's cycling race where
the gold and silver medals were won by
two biological males identifying as
trans women now this is the latest in a
long series of these faral results in
women's sport which are clearly eroding
the fairness and equality and integrity
of women's sport and my question is
simply why are we still allowing this to
happen why why a are official Sports
bodies not just Banning it completely
when there's such an obvious
disadvantage vage to women born with Fe
female biological bodies but secondly um
why aren't more women standing up is it
because the ones who do get get
crucified at the altar of transactivism
well I hear AA touting next to me so I'm
fearful of what I'm about to say but
look first of all on the trans women in
in in women's sports thing I we're all
looking for the next I don't know what
to say I mean it is so obvious we have
had Richard Dawkins on trigonometry
Sharon Davis the former British Olympics
women detailing bit by bit by bit every
way in which men have a physical
advantage over women when it comes to
physical competition and by the way you
don't need to be a scientist you just
need to have a brain look around to know
that there is a physical difference
between men and women uh as for why more
women don't stand up look first of all I
think we should acknowledge there are
many many very courageous women who have
uh spoken out about this and I just
mentioned Sharon Davis but I could give
you a list as long as my arm but I do
actually
jky yes of course I I generally don't
buy into sort of allegations that men
and women are treated differently in
lots of different fields but I do think
actually on this issue uh it is true
women I think are perceived as being
slightly more vulnerable and the Very
hateful bigot to trans activists that go
after people especially online uh they
do seem to Target the women more so I
think it's actually on the men in and
the women in this case but particularly
on the men to stand up and lead in
saying this is completely ridiculous and
it needs to
end okay AA my question for you when was
the last time a trans man competed
against biological men and beat them I
just don't think that we would have that
level of introspection it's probably
that journalists aren't trying to hunt
out that story because they don't think
it's going to make headline news look at
the moment no no no no no no no no no aa
aa it hasn't happened that's why no
one's written about it look at the
moment no one writes about trans men
winning against men because they don't
beat them PE at the moment we are
currently you know we're currently
witnessing the trial of ban gay who was
you know a young trans girl who you know
sadly lost her life and you know we'll
have to see what comes out of the court
I can't say too much more on it but also
you know a colleague of mine just
returned from a a young trans boy who
taken his own life the way that we are
treating trans people in this country is
disgusting there is such a small
proportion of them and I don't
understand hang why we won't leave them
alone yeah but one of the reasons why
trans people people are getting a hard
time is because of this ridiculous
defense of the indefensible over the
issue of trans athletes and women's
sport it makes an absolute mockery of
all trans people I know trans people who
wish us would all just go away that
trans people would stop trying to fight
at this ridiculous alar of unfairness
and battle for their own fairness and
equality they no I think what they're
fighting for is just to be recognized
and just to be left alone you know I it
doesn't need to be this headline media
speculation ins sanity all the time if
perhaps the media showed some care for
them every other day of the year then
maybe we could have a sensible
conversation about sport maybe I could
you know start talking to you normally
about perhaps what is going on you know
with the cycling but frankly I don't
really care when I know that trans
people are taking their own lives every
single day what about the women who are
competing in these Sports and who are
not getting an opportunity to compete
fairly Sur have for them Constantine
I've loved having you back please come
back again soon AA always good to have
you we'll agree to disagree than thank
you very much and for watching from my
home here in London I suspect I'll be
here again tomorrow night and Thursday
night from covid Central whatever
your we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
they have made a statement condemning
Hamas we expect to see the crown revisit
Harry's antiemetic Halloween costume
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well well trained most dog owners will
tell you a dog can turn you know what I
love about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what rashak has done the question now
is what he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomim
there's not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a f or a
tragedy talk TV has spoken exclusively
to a member of the Blade Runners do you
have a message for Sadi Khan we're not
stopping until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so £40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC Mouse man
MC mous man MC mous man he should be
easy enough to catch this guy shouldn't
he I mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz